tan sólo unos días después de suspender
los vuelos procedentes de brasil francia
superó los 100 mil decesos por 19 por lo
que las autoridades dicen que podrían
adoptar restricciones de viaje más
estrictas que guarden mucho juego se
esperan más medidas robustas como las de
brasil para todos los países donde
consideremos que una variante peligrosa
es dominante y donde creamos que hay una
explosión de esos casos o si en general
hay una fuerte presencia del comicio 9
la cifra de los 100 mil decesos llega en
medio de la tercera ola del virus en
francia más de 31 mil personas están
hospitalizadas actualmente por kobe 19 y
cerca de 6 mil pacientes están en
unidades de cuidado intensivo
la esposa del lyon el petit pass está
entre las víctimas murió por kobe 19 en
marzo del año pasado y no tuvo la
oportunidad de despedirse de ella
debidamente subieron a mi esposa a la
ambulancia cerraron las puertas y a
través de la ventana me saludó con la
mano después de eso no la volvía a ver
ni viva ni muerta
lionel lleva mucho tiempo reivindicando
un día nacional para rendir
a las víctimas de kobe 19 porque un día
nacional de luto
simplemente porque todos nuestros
muertos están yendo sin ningún respeto
sin dignidad humana sin ningún
reconocimiento y hasta que no se pruebe
lo contrario no son sólo números las
autoridades dicen que manuel macrón está
debatiendo con el gobierno para
establecer un día de homenaje para
recordar a todos los que han sucumbido
al virus